hi guys joe million from hartwig here
with a quick around the horn on aot mill
uh aot mill is a it stands for advanced
one touch integrated graphics function
and it's a software that's been around
on the akuma mills for some time but
it's becoming standard on
some of the genos line from here forward
it's available as an add-on option to
existing machine tools out in the field
uh one of the things that igf mill or
aot mill is really great for is that
quick down and dirty programming that
you might need to do whenever you were
working on uh whenever you're working on
the shop floor uh it might be really
handy for the guy on the floor to maybe
use for cutting some vice draws or
something real quickly or handling some
process that maybe somebody up in
the programming department didn't have
the foresight to handle
uh another good use case for it would be
uh
would be for shops that
don't have the uh
the overhead or don't have quite the
volume uh to
move themselves into cam or cad cam
programming uh or invest in a fully
featured cam system
what aot is not great for it's not great
at highly complex work or work involving
surfaces if you have a lot of complex
curves or surfaces i don't recommend aot
for you you're going to be struggling
and finding yourself frustrated
um
that being said let's uh let's get to
going around the horn here
when you're running a machine in aot you
might see this window whenever you first
walk up to it i've got this machine
running in aot mode right now so
uh we can run this machine without ever
having to edit or change any of the code
for machines that have aot whenever we
come over here to the program button and
we click
on this button here
we will have our nc program data which
we're used to seeing but we'll also have
our igf data here and most of our igf
data usually comes out of the folder aot
here if i look here i've got a few
programs i've programmed already i'm
going to go ahead and create a new one
i'm going to call this aot
create
igf data i'm going to call this aot
dash mill
we want to be capslock on aot-mil
[Music]
and then i'm going to make this 2
because i've already done this exact
file before
if i hit enter here and then okay
now i've got my aot mil2 that we'll be
machining on one of the first things
that asks us is what our blank material
is made out of i could change this type
of material here by entering a number
i'm just machining electrons inside of a
simulator here so my feeds and speeds
aren't really critical to me but you
know very often you might find that uh
5150 aluminum has different cutting
speeds than maybe a 400 series stainless
it does pick out feeds and speeds from a
chart automatically and that chart can
be configured and if you don't like the
automatic feeds and speeds you can of
course override them
the next thing that it's going to ask
for is which origin i want to use i'm
just going to be using work offset one
for all of this
and then after that it's going to ask us
some questions about our part shape so
i have about an extra hundred thousands
hanging over in each direction and
outside of that it's just a six by two
block with the origin in the top left
corner
once i've determined my shape i can go
right into adding features the first
feature that i'd like to add here is let
me show you my part
i'm six inches long
two inches
two inches uh thick
i've got a pocket that's an inch and a
half
wide by three inches long the print's a
little hard to see here
uh that's about a half inch deep with
three quarter radius pockets and i've
got a half inch radius on this one
corner of the part here
so whenever i go to maschine feature i
want a feature add
click ok here for offset one we'll do a
contour
i can rename my contour at this point if
i'd like
my outside works for me is a contour
name
my cut depth will be how deep this
particular contour is going it's going a
half inch deep i'm only wanting to rough
this particular contour i'll go into
adding
a rough and a finish operation later but
it's important to note we can rough
finish rough and finish or rough
semi-finish and finish with each
operation
whenever i go into my tool diameter i
can tell it what tool diameter i want i
don't have a five inch end mill i've got
a half inch in mill might be a little
more appropriate and this stock removal
box is my width of cut
so
with this particular cutter whenever i'm
machining electrons inside of a
simulator i think a quarter of an inch
step over will do just fine
the next field that it's asking me for
is to perform an auto decision on the
tool
so when i'm machining one of the or
whenever i'm inside igf and i click this
tool auto decision button it's going to
look at the tools that are installed on
the machine in the magazine
and try to determine which tool might be
appropriate there happens to be a half
inch end mill in there already
so whenever i click that it brings up an
end mill it's tool number 101 i didn't
even have to worry about that it pulled
in my spindle speeds it pulled in my
feeds and speeds for me from the table
chart automatically and i don't even
have to really spend too much time with
that either
now it's asking me for the shape that i
want to define
my shape is going to be arbitrary here
whenever we're doing an outside contour
there's not many other options available
and once i click that it'll ask for my
start point so i can give it a start
point of my start point will be zero
zero
and zero
my offset direction would be left
my relief amount
i like to type space and hit enter to
clear both of those fields you could
leave those fields there if you needed
to jump over a clamp or something like
that
and we'll leave that in condition okay
the next thing we'll do is we'll pay
attention to these little cursor logos
over here on the lower right hand side
of the screen they correspond with these
different arrows in the different
directions that you might want to draw
from our start point so from here i want
to move to x of 6 so i'm going to type 6
to select that direction then i'm going
to go to an x of 6 in that direction
and enter the next move the next
position that i want to go to draw this
shape would be down in y
so if i hit 2 i can move down in y and
i'm moving to a y of negative two inches
my drawing that i had had a contour on
that or had a radius on the one corner i
can add a radius chamfer if i type the
equal key here
it'll bring me up to a dialogue where it
asks for the radius
i can go ahead and add that and notice
that it doesn't draw it just yet but it
will draw whenever i complete the line
back to x 0 here
now i've got both that radius here and
my line continuing around to
x0
and then i want to go ahead and i want
to finish this shape up to a y of zero
as well
so that gives me my basic shape on this
contour that it's going to try to
machine
and now i can click the next approach
and escape positions
for this particular method it gave me an
approach and escape position that i
think is okay it's going to try to
come in on this corner and it's going to
try to come out on this corner
and then it's going to do that with the
perpendicular line method that is
perfectly fine for what we're trying to
do right here
if i hit end
now i've got my shape there i can hit
end here
and i can go to machining test
and
if i hit cycle start here it'll do a lap
around the box now i see something there
that i might want to change
so let me go back and change that real
tip real quick so if i quit here on this
box here where it describes my cutting
speed or if my list of tools is they're
going to run i might change my cut depth
to be 0.75 because i only want it to
make one pass around the outside of the
part instead of two
i hit end now i go back to my machining
test
and i cycle start
now i've only got that one pass in depth
around the part
i do want to add another feature here we
want to put that pocket in there and
then i have one more little bonus
feature i'm going to try to add to this
part
so
if i want to add another feature from
here i go to machining feature
i want to make sure i move down to a
fresh line here
and then i can go feature add
my origin number will be
one and my clearance plane will still be
that two hundred thousands that i used
in the first one that's okay
i wanna select a pocket this time which
is option number three there i can call
this pocket one that works for me my cut
depth i'm going to go with 0.375 for
this particular tool
i'm going to
this time instead of just rough it i'm
going to use the rough and finish so i'm
going to use number three here to give
me the rough and finish
and then that'll give me a rough tool
that or i can determine now what my
rough tool diameter will be
half an inch will be good enough for my
rough tool diameter and i want to use a
quarter inch for my finished tool
diameter i think that will give me a
better result on the inside of that
pocket
i'm not going to bother to pre-drill any
holes but i am going to do my tool auto
decision and so whenever i hit f4
it will bring up these two tools and it
picked for me a tool that i had on tool
101 that's already in use in this
program and then for my second tool to
finish that pocket it picked tool number
125 which was a quarter inch end mill
that was already in it it brought in
again my feeds and speeds from the table
that was pre-defined
uh
from here
i didn't define my shape oh shape
designate now we'll define our shape
i'm just going to say this is a simple
square
i'll put my start point in corner 4 here
because i think that makes it the
easiest for my particular pocket to be
defined
my reference point there will be x of a
quarter inch y negative one point or y
negative point two five inches
and then my cut height will be zero from
there
i'm going to go ahead and hit space and
then enter to get rid of that clearance
amount
my side length dx will be three inches
my side length v y will be 1.5 inches in
this case my rotate angle will be zero
in my chamfering i'm going to go ahead
and give it a
radius chamfer with a number two and i'm
going to define that radius to be 0.375
inches
there i have my pocket
now i can go to generate my approach and
escape positions
so my approach motion here
i'm going to say for my approach motion
that maybe i want to do a
helical entry instead of a perpendicular
entry here so let's see if it'll let me
change that uh entry motion
to
a arc
approach escape
next cut motion
my cut motion is going to be
helical
it's a number two
my cut position i'm going to make
optional as well
because i want to move my if we see this
red circle here
i want to move that entry point to maybe
be an x of 2
and a y of 1 negative 1.0
so that entry motion is not trying to
define on being defined on the edge of
that arc
outside of that i think the rest of my
entry arc will work okay
and then i could hit end here or we
could come in and we could uh play
around with the
other shapes that we needed to play with
uh for their entry motions as well but
it's only that roughing tool that i want
to really helix in anyway
and
so now if i come in here
i hit end here and i do my machining
test
cycle start
i've got my
part there as i've defined it so far i
want to make a couple more changes i see
to this because i didn't uh
i don't think maybe our finishing tool
needs to machine that floor so one of
the things that i can do now that i've
seen that i open this up
i can come in here if i go feature
condition switch go to my second page
i can turn my face wall separation on
and then i can turn my face cut so i'm
not cutting the floor
of that pocket with my finishing tool
again
and i'm only going to be finishing on
the wall
then hit ok here or end here
and that
should
whenever i go to machining test this
now we shouldn't see that finishing tool
yep it just goes around the outside of
the pocket it doesn't go to finish the
floor of the pocket anymore
we put here i have one more quick
feature to show you on uh this
particular quick around the horn here
uh i would like to add a machining
feature that is
less a feature and more an existing
program so at some point in time you're
going to have data that you want to get
either
either you know this pro this software
wasn't capable of handling the shape
you're going to have something that's
too complex and you need a sub program
to handle or something like that
and this particular function i'm getting
ready to demonstrate will do that if i
go instead of selecting contour groove
or pocket here if i go to machining
feature 2
and i go to this nc program tab
it'll allow me to add i want to pull a
tool out i'm going to pick an engraving
tool
got my spindle rpm i'm gonna go ahead
and slow down my spindle with 5000 rpm
just because my first cutting position
for this particular uh
for this particular uh feature is going
to be an x of
i'm going to say 0.25 should work for us
and a y of negative 1.5 i imagine would
work pretty well
our first cutting position in z will
make zero
our coolant on off we could control all
of that if we really wanted to
but that's not so much what we're
looking for i'm looking for this program
edit button
and so whenever we're using this
particular feature it will
bring our tool in for us and bring it to
that start point we defined and then
it'll leave us leave it up to us to
define what to do from here and i happen
to have written an engraving program
that's capable of engraving serial
numbers on parts and i'm going to try to
run that program inside of that pocket
we engraved
eng
it will
do a serial number s num
and then
i think i'm going to get a random number
here
just to prove that it's a random number
generator i'll go with 407
s num equals 407.
i have to give this particular cycle of
feed rate
at 200 inches per minute and a depth
we'll make a negative 0.4 so we go 200
thousandths into our 375 000 steep
pocket that should be all the
information i need to give this sub
program to make it engrave the number
407 in the bottom of that pocket
and then we'll hit feature complete
here
and we can go to machining
end here and now we can go to machining
test now it will complain that it can't
draw everything here
because
this particular uh
this particular preview window does not
have access to the code that's causing
that sub program to work but it will
work in reality on the machine
hit okay here
we can still
cycle start this watch our program go
around and it would or if we watched
real quick it showed where that start
point came in but then it quickly moved
out of the way
quit here
so when we want to go to run an igf file
one of the situ one of the options that
we have is to uh
is to run it as an igf file and if we
want to do that we can hit this end
slash machining button and then i can
hit this save and machining button as
well
that automatically selected the part
file
it brought the code for it which i've up
until this point not seen
into right here
and then it'll allow me to go straight
into the animated simulation
and run the part
the machine is going to get a tool
it's coming down it's running that
cutter around the outside of the part
and this is happening in real life by
the way
uh the machine that
this is on
or most of the machines you would be
programming with aot wouldn't have cast
this particular simulator does so here
is a something this simulator thinks is
a real machine going around the outside
and here is the graphical demonstration
that you'd have inside of igf or inside
of a machine equipped with igf to
preview that
there i'm heliking into the pocket
it's machining the pocket for us
this pocket cycle can be edited and
changed and you can go from more of a
spiral end spiral out there's a lot of
custom
custom ability there
maybe i want to bump up my feeds and
speeds a little bit because i don't want
to waste so much of your time watching
this run
i'm going to machine a second depth pass
here
it'll finish around the outside
and now it'll go get our finishing tool
that we were going to use for the pocket
to make this bigger
do the outside of the pocket
and i made a typo in my
deal here
whenever i'm doing one of these files i
can go straight in here
i forgot an equal sign and my pd equals
four that was my programming mistake
here
and
i'm going to since i'm at it speed all
of these speeds and feeds up too so we
don't waste so much time the second time
around
do that right here on the fly it doesn't
know what my speeds and feeds are for
that
we're going to go in machining saving
machining
and now i can try to run that all again
oops
i have the wrong tool command let's fix
that real quick
gonna be in manual mode
this does think it's a real machine
i'm gonna have to hit prepare start
whenever i'm running in this particular
cycle
now i can hit start again
and if i go window change
display change to animated simulation
we'll get this part drawn up here
a little more cleanly
machining that pocket
helical down a little further here
machine another pass on that pocket
now we'll machine the outsides or semi
finish the inside of that pocket more or
less and now it'll come back with a
finishing tool
to finish the walls of this pocket
again this machine thinks it's a real
machine running in real life at the
moment
now it's going to come in with the
engraving tool and it's going to engrave
our number in that pocket
there's our four
there's our zero
and there's our seven
our engraving program is done
and that concludes our
the the the entry part of our
presentation there is one more thing i
want to point out here that
uh i don't always have to use this
particular view or this particular
option whenever i'm doing an igf file
another thing i could have done earlier
whenever i ran into that mistake or
another thing i could have done from the
beginning
would be to open this file and rather
than hit this in machining box i could
hit this program create
and i could make the file
i could give it a program name if i
really want to i don't need to i'm just
going to create and select that file
and now if i look at this this window
will look a little different and this is
probably what more people are used to
seeing whenever they look at a
an akuma mill with a p300 or later
controller
but this will still all work the same
way but what this does now is instead of
whenever i hit edit it bringing back up
igf for me to edit the edit file i've
got my quick edit button and i could
have come in here and just changed that
one character that i was missing if i
really wanted to
i'm going to save that file without
saving or i'm going to exit that without
saving my file file save okay no
and we're just going to run another
quick test
on this to make sure that it's still
doing what we want it to do
there it's going around the outside
but now here we're running from a more
traditional program
more like we typically would if we were
posting out of a cam system what's nice
about this is that you can edit the code
you know even the best of cam systems
occasionally have some little straggly
code that you don't want that you want
to optimize way
igf will be no different
in that regard
so if you if you're one of those people
that want to highly optimize your code
outputting code like this may be a
better option if you're one of those
people who's really timid and afraid of
afraid of messing with the g-code you
can generally run from igf and never
have to edit any of the code directly
now we're going to come back and we're
going to machine the outside of the
pocket
or the very outside pass of the
internals of that pocket more precisely
maybe
and we'll come back with the engraver
and engrave that
for
[Music]
no seven
all right again my name is joe million
i'm with hartwig and i hope you enjoyed
this presentation thank you